hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar about expanded carrier screening
research in the genomic era
i am alan rico of thermo facial
scientific and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
thermofacial scientific to learn more
visit
thermofacial.com rh by ngs
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like now to welcome our speaker dr
doran there
founder and the ceo of identify
dr berar you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody everybody well heard
we can hear you though perfect so
good morning everybody good evening or
i don't know which time zones are here
it's really a pleasure to present
to you this presentation about
preconception screening
we are going to focus this presentation
on
actually understanding what
preconception is and then we are going
to
dive into understanding of what is
residual risk
and reproductive risks we are going to
make it by also using some
live examples and i would be more than
happy to receive
a questions to answer during the
presentation at the end of it actually
we are going to have
a 15 minutes for president for questions
at the end
or if following this conversation
any of you wants to contact me and ask
questions i would be more than happy to
answer them let's just start with
the disclaimer some formalities so we're
just going to read it
so i just want to clarify that i am not
a thermofisher employee and therefore
i'm
reading that terraficial scientific and
its affiliates are not endorsing
recommending or promoting any use
or application of thermo fisher
scientific products presented by third
parties
during the seminar information materials
presented or provided by third parties
are provided as is and without warranty
of any kind including regarding
intellectual property rights and develop
their reported
results parties presenting images text
and material represent
they they have the right to do so so
that is
a disclaimer and with this we can go to
discuss preconception
so there's been a lot of progress in the
last two decades
in the field of preconception prenatal
testing that we can allow the patients
so as you all know we have started to
use
in a in a very robust in in
much higher volumes chromosomal micro
analysis
which started already roughly two
decades and today many many
societies are declaring that chromosomal
microarray analysis
is the first tier test for different
medical conditions we are not going to
deal with it
during this presentation and then you
are all familiar of course with nipt
so that is our ability to check if
a pregnant woman
is carrying an embryo who is usually one
of the three trisomies
18 21 and 13 and actually
in 10 weeks pregnancy which of course is
a great advance
and now we are speaking more and more
about the new revolution which is
actually expected care screening
and what is expanded care streaming so
as you all know
we are going towards a situation in
which
larger and larger parts of our genome
will be made available to
populations which means that we do
anticipate that our genome is going to
be part of the medical records of each
individual worldwide
that means of course that we can use
more and more parts of the genomes
to try and prevent the live births of
kids
suffering from monogenic autosomal
recessive
disorders and if we're going to look at
it and try to see what is the magnitude
of this
of this phenomena as a sec then
we all know that tries to be 21 of
course in the the young ages is roughly
one to eight hundred and fifty live
births
and i believe that many will recommend
and will agree that this is a syndrome
that is worth
screening for if we are going to take a
look at
all monogenic disorders then we do have
something like 6000
hormone phenotypes so if you are going
to look to the online mendelian
inherited
website you will be you will find
roughly 6 000
that together are actually having an
incidence
which is almost three times higher than
trisomy 21
and it is actually one in 300 verse so
if we do things that we need to screen
for this one
it makes a lot of sense to include
preconception screening
for every couple planning pregnancy if
we're going to look at even one more
number
so let's take it only severe phenotypes
two phenotypes which has
a either multisystemic damage
or mental incognition syndromes like
disartistic bodies
that we are still going to be in roughly
one to six hundred life births
which is still higher than 2021
so that gave a lot of motivation
to try and offer a
preconception screening which is as
large as possible and we are going to
see examples very
shortly if we do want to take
a very brief overview of what is
autosomal recessive inheritance
then we have the mother we have the
father each of them is having one allen
from
their respective mothers and their
respective father same here
and in this particular case you can see
that the mother
is healthy carrier of an allele which is
called b
and a mutation specific mutation which
is this allele
and the father is also carrier
so this couple are completely healthy
individuals
but they are carrying each the same
mutation
in a given gene and then you can see
that actually 25 percent
of their kids would be will inherit the
a and
a the two normal copies and their
phenotype
would be healthy and there will be no
carriers
50 percent of their kids will actually
present the same healthy phenotype but
since they will
inherit one defected allele
with this specific mutation then they
are going to be healthy carriers
and 25 percent are actually
getting both defected alerts one from
the healthy mother
one from the healthy father and they
will be sick
in a homozygote state because they will
have
the same mutation affecting
both copies of the gene there is of
course another way
for to someone recessive to be presented
which is compounded for zagosity
which in this time the green color
represents a different mutation in the
same gene
so once again the mother is healthy she
has
one normal copy one defective copy
with a red mutation and the father has
one normal copy and one defected copy
with the green mutation the end results
will be the same
25 heavy phenotype non-carriers
50 percent healthy carriers and 25
percent
sick but in a compounded prosecutive
state
because both
the two copies of the genes are defected
but each of them
because of a different mutation
in preconception screenings there also
including many times
x-linked disorders like the screening
for fragile leaks like the screening for
duchenne muscular dystrophy and others
and in this situation naturally we must
remember
that a mother can be a carrier so she
would have one
normal ex one defected ex the father
has only one ex and this is why fathers
are either sick or
healthy but because many of the
ex-length disorders are not allowing to
make it to a productive health
and a reproductive age and so on then
almost always
the fathers of course will be healthy
and their eggs would be normal
and in this case but that we can see is
we can see
that there is actually a chance of 50
from the males to be
sick that means that females
will receive one egg from the mother one
egg from the father and will be healthy
and made if you will receive x and y
from the father
of course will be healthy as well and
then
it is enough that the mother will
transmit
her ex to a male offspring
that the kid will be sick so that means
here
is independent of the father's genotype
it is dependent of the inheritance of
the mother
and this is why it is a risk state as
well
we do not screen usually for orthosomal
dominant disorders
so this is why i'm not going to detail
it but naturally the
the inheritance of autosomal dominant is
a
are clear and should they you can get
familiar with them elsewhere
now let's define a little bit what is
prenatal screening
so prenatal screening is one of the
pillars of prevention medicine
of genomic medicine or precision
medicine we want to prevent
diseases and prenatal screening
is the systematic search for a specific
condition
among a large asymptomatic subpopulation
selected by demographic characteristics
such as age sex or ethnicity
screening typically identifies at risk
groups for further diagnostic testings
that is very important because many
people are saying
yes we don't need to be screened because
we are healthy
these are exactly the individuals that
needs to be screened
because carriers are asymptomatic and
this is why
preconception screening is suggested to
all the population in campaigns of
screening
rather than to people who are sick
because those who are sick we already
know that they are sick
so that is very very important to
realize this
and screening is different from
diagnosis
diagnosis refers to any of the
diagnostic procedures
used to determine whether the fetus has
a genetic abnormality
so that means if we screen the parents
and we find that they are both carriers
we do not know if the embryo
will be sick we only know a diagnostic
procedure will only be
if for example by amniosynthesis we are
going to take
genomic material from the embryo and
know
exactly what the embryo carries so this
is very important
and one more important definition
is what is prenatal so prenatal is
actually
everything before the delivery
of the kid and there might be population
in which preconception screening is
doing premarital
before marrying some preconception
before the woman is pregnant
prenatal is during pregnancy so some
might do
preconception screening still within the
pregnancy let's say the beginning of the
pregnancy
naturally these couples will lose
some treatment modalities such as ivf
and pgd
that can be offered to people who did
preconception screening
before the pregnancy and then we have
two more
terms which we should not be confused
with them one is perinatal which means
immediately after birth and you know
that there are genetic screening
they are screening either biochemical or
genetics which are being done for
example for hypothyroidism
and for phenylketonuria so that is
perinatal
and then there is also postnatal which
is let's say
a few months age or a year later on so
these terms
has to be distinguished and again we are
trying of course
each couple has the right to choose what
they prefer to do
but we are trying to get to the
preconception state with the screening
because that means that we will be able
to
enter into interfere and intervent
with their pregnancy before the wound is
pregnant
because you know that pregnancy is of
course something that is
the clock is taking and we can stop them
so
what are the reasons now for the thermal
recessive disorders in different human
populations
so there are many cases in which there
is founder effects
which means that a small group of people
have give
population and by chance by drift
many recessive alerts are in the
population
one can note the finnish heritage
disorders
the amish population ashkenazi jewish
population
and so on another reason
for autozone recessive disorders and an
example of the middle east is being
given here
here because consanguinity is practiced
often
which means that two first-degree
cousins
might give a beverage to a kid
that has a defected identical
copy from the father from the mother
because of an
identity by descent state so that's
another
another of course reason and as you can
see in the pedigree
usually consequinity is being
shown by two lines then there are also
genes in which there is some ethnic
damage to the genes which is try to
imagine that this is like
a bed road with repeated accidents in it
because there is a bed crossroad or
whatever you want to say
and those are the heroblobinopathies so
thalassemia alpha
and beta cystic fibrosis spinal muscular
atrophy
duchenne muscular dystrophy and fragile
x
actually in one case the mobile
menopause as you know
carriers sometimes have some protection
from diseases like malaria
so this is usually the reasons for
having autosomal recessive disorders
and the rationale behind suggesting its
population
and as you can see in the past if we are
going to take a look to the policy
statements
then we speak about cystic fibrosis a
given
disease or european
jewish descent which means that the
the focus was on specific genes
and specific populations ethnic specific
per specific usually it was severe
diseases
of high incidence usually the screening
was sequential
which means let's say that first the
the mother is going and then the father
of the pregnancy is going
and it was of course under the
supervision of medical geneticist
and informed consent process but as we
are
advancing with our knowledge about
genomics we can think about
a lot of reasons why we want to expand
the test
let's start looking to them so first as
we said at the beginning of this
presentation
we want to allow campaigns that are
compatible is a genomic error which
means we know more
about more genes we want to give more to
our patient to the population so we
are going to be in a better health state
then they are changing demographies
in many population there are inter
communal marriage
and there are change residencies and as
you know for example in the united
states
there are hundreds of languages
sometimes
spoken at a very very precise location
like
queens in new york and so on then
what we found was that some photo
mutations
that were associated in the past let's
say with
finns you can also find them and write
in lower frequencies
about other europeans let's say so why
not include them
then we have plethora of mutations
which means that we would like to
suggest a robust
plex technology we don't want to start
screening one by one with means like
rflps document and so on we are looking
for
major modalities that we allow to
screens for thousands of variants
simultaneously
and usually of course we are mentioning
either
arrays microarrays or nest generation
sequencing
technologies and then
many patients are actually tested during
ongoing pregnancy
that mandates a rapid and comprehensive
test so still
we have data from this in between one
third
one half of the couplers are actually
becoming familiar with preconception
screenings
during the first trimester of the
pregnancy and they are doing it
only then and because the clock is
ticking in pregnancy we would like to
have
a very very fast way to receive the
samples of the lab and do the testing
and then we are familiar today more and
more with
sperm and egg donations which are often
being
brought to the community from external
communities
from of course many different reasons so
that is
a that is the reason for us to wants to
do it i should also of course
mention that many simply don't know or
the first reports of origin
and it's a very good way to screen all
the people
for the same panels and then you can
eliminate
this test and indeed the present
we are speaking about an ethnic
screening
so expensive telescopic in reproductive
medicine points to consider
expanded screening is not anymore
for a single disease carrier screening
in the age of genomic medicine
microphenotypes might be included many
times there's a recommendation
to screen the reproductive partners to
get the two samples of the lab
in a concurrent way because they're
likely
to find that one of the couple is a
carrier
is of course very high and this is why
we would like to alleviate attention and
know immediately
whether the couple have
both carriers or not and then of course
we still want to have medical geneticist
and informed consent for all couples
doing it
importantly i would like to mention it
just happened last week so in between
the time where
we have submitted this presentation a
for
a for approval and until today
the american college of medical genetics
and genomics have actually issued
a new guidelines which are of course
fully concordant
which what we are saying here and now
after we went through the understanding
of what is
big conception screening i'm going to
move into
a live example of cystic fibrosis
which we are going to take it and see
what are all the definitions of carriers
residual risks reproductive risk and so
on
so cystic fibrosis is a complex and
multi-systemic disorders which is being
inherited
in an autosomal recessive manner and it
is actually the most common
life-limiting autosomal recessive
in persons of north european heritage so
that is of course
giving a lot of motivation to screen for
it
especially as it is one in 2500
live births which are being affected
with it and we also know that cystic
fibrosis
is being caused only because of cf
because of the cftr gene so that means
that we have a lot of good motivation
to be using this
now
if we need now to define
who are the carriers
what are the careers so how many
individuals in the population are
actually
carrying a mutation if
we know that there is one in two
thousand and five hundred life births
of c kids so the carrier frequency
is actually the proportion of
individuals in a population
with a single copy of a specific
specific recessive genetic
variants and
how are we going to go to these numbers
if
if we know what is the actual frequency
of the disease
let me try showing to you how we are
doing it
[Music]
so if we are going to
so can you i i'm having some strange
messages from the software i hope you
can hear me yes we can
okay so let me go ahead
just one second okay if you can hear me
that we can go ahead
so if we are going now to take a look
how we're going to do it
let's take again the results of the
cystic fibrosis screening and let's see
how are we calculating back
if this is a disease we know the
frequency is 1 to 2
500 how are we doing this so
if we are going to go and know that 1 in
25
is a carrier the risk
that a mother will randomly fight with
randomly
have a reproductive partner with a
father
which is one in 20 is only 25 as well
and it's one in 25 times one in 25
and then only one quarter of the kids
are going to be affected
so it brings us back to the exact number
that we said
one in 2500
life birth cases for cystic fibrosis
of course we can use it now to do it to
reverse engineer it
so that means that if we know that a
given disease
is 1 in 2 500 then we also know
that it is that it is
we can divide by 4 and take
and then take the square root out and
then we will be able
to find out what is the frequency of the
disease
so let's try to do it ourselves so let's
say
that we have now a population
with an incidence of cf which is one in
one hundred thousand
live births we are going to take it back
if we are going to take it back then we
are going to see
that if
we are going to find 25 000 and there
we account for random mating so the
square root of 25 000
is 158 and therefore the carrier
frequency is
1 to 158 as simple as that
so if you know what is the frequency of
a disease in your population
you have to divide it by four then take
the square root
and then you will have the carrier
frequency
of this one
now what is the residual risk the
residual risk
is the amount of risk or danger
associated with an action or event
remaining after all after natural or
inherent risk have been reduced by risk
controls
what does it mean let's say
that there is a couple that did a
screening
for cystic fibrosis and
they are both negative does it mean that
there is
zero chance for a kid with cystic
fibrosis
the answer for this is no they still
have a risk because we have eliminated
maybe
much of the risk but not all of it which
depends for example on the number of
mutations that we're screened for
on the accuracy of the method and on
their ethnicity
that we have to understand now that the
actual
tunnel which is being used for the
preconception screening
is critical to understand what is the
situation
so we might think about two different
type of panels
there might be a pathogenic variant
panel which is a test that analyzes
multiple variants and trust for
preconceptions such as mutations
so let's say that we are screening 23
mutations
for cystic fibrosis we are not reading
the food gene
we are only going to mutations that we
know that are in high frequency
and then different from this is a gene
panel
which is a test that analyzes multiple
genes
so this test will attempt to read the
full length of a gene
and see whether
it is there are any mutations
that can found there a good example
would be
whether a for the first one
is arrays which means that
we are putting on an array infinite
number
of quotations that should be screened
for and we are going to screen only for
this mutation
as compared to preconception screening
based on the gene panel
which we are going to try to read all
the genes
and find all types of mutations of
course we might also find notations
or variants that we don't know what is
their meaning often known as violence of
unknown clinical significance
so therefore it is critical for us to
understand
what is the detection rate of our test
because the detection rate
will affect directly the residual risk
the proportion of individuals with a
particular conduction
who tests positive for that condition
when measured by a gold standard
methodology
is the detection rate so we need to
understand
how many people what percentage of the
mutations
that we want to screens are actually
going to be captured
by the panel we are using because that
will allow us
to understand what is the detection rate
of the carriers within a given
population
so if we're going to take a look to this
then let's take a look for cftr for
example
so for many years for general population
the american college of medical genetics
recommended 23 mutations
but as you can see in caucasians
that the population care frequency was 1
in 25
the detection rate was 88
for hispanic american it was 79
for asian american it went all the way
down to 49
so that means that this 23 23 mutations
cannot capture all
the variants affecting populations it is
varying depending on the population
as you can see indeed the
final results post-testing
is going to be different based on the
detection rate that this specific panel
can allow
and if we're going to go back to system
fibonacci again and we are going to take
a vivid example then if we take
a carrier rate of 1 in 25 a detection
rate of 97
which means that in a given individual
from ashkenazi jewish origin if we
screen the 23 mutations that we just
discussed
we are going to detect 97
of the variants affecting this
population
if we are going to put it into the
probabilities
formula which is being brought here to
you
which is taking into consideration prior
probability for a carrier
conditional probability which is what
does it mean if there is a negative
result
and eventually if an
individual or much cannot be jewish
ancestry when we know that the
prior probability is 125 and we know
that the detection rate is 97
at the end of the test if is if he is
negative he or she
are negative then the residual risk
is still going to be 1 in 801
once again negative result
on a residual risk panel is
never eliminating the possibility to be
a carrier and therefore never
eliminating the possibility of a sick
kid it's of course making it much more
likely
and if we are going to take a look to
different scenarios
then you see that if we take the same
example fresh canadian jews caucasian
and
and asian with the up priority frequency
carrier frequencies
with the different detection rates which
are being suggested by this 23 mutation
fund and
let's say then we see that the residual
risks
differ dramatically of course you can
understand
that this is why we want to move into
more and more mutations being screened
not only 23
but hundreds of mutations of full gene
sequencing because then the detections
weight would be
much higher and the residual risk would
go
far below and that is the story of
expanded preconception screening
elevating the detection rate so that per
population
we can get much lower residual risk
let's go back to our couple and take a
look at them
so we know that a priori as you already
know
1 in 25 times 125
sorry 1 in 25 and 1 in 25
time 1 and 4 the up your risk is
1 in 2 500.
kids would be affected however
post the test if now the mother was
screened
and she has one to eight hundred and one
and the father has won in eight hundred
of one because they are both ashkenazi
jews and they they took the test
then now the test the chance for a c kid
is one in 801 times 1 in 801
time quarter which brings us to one in
roughly 2.5 million
which is of course very very low but
again
not zero so
as you know now we need to do it
ourselves
so let's calculate it for a new one we
see f and the mother is of ashkenazi
jewish origin and she is not tested
the father is of east asian ancestry and
he is tested
so now we are going to take a look at it
if the mother is of a kennedy jewish
ancestry and she was not tested she is
one in 25
if the father is of asian ancestry was
tested
he is one in 203 so that means that now
the overall risk is 125 times once in
203
times one in four which is one in twenty
thousand
now
we are going to see another very
important thing which
might affect which might affect if
a detection rate so as you can see
the issue of no calls so one individual
is being stringed for a given noun
number of rotations and theoretically
in a given specific genotyping procedure
one of the mutations can not work simply
because of a you know
technical lab issue which is something
we are all familiar with
naturally that will affect the overall
residual risk because it will affect the
detection rate
so again for this carpel of ashkenazi
jewish origin
42 are from this rotation
which means that if this rotation is
dropping from one test
then of course it affects dramatically
the detection rate
so this is why it is important to be
aware
of the no course and naturally
if we go ahead now this means that we
need to know
what to do with no consultations
and this is why if we allow
using the software of identify to
actually
choose variants that will be handled
differently
if they have failed in the genotyping so
one have
an opportunity to identify a must-have
variant
which means that if this variant for any
given reason
is failing the system will block the
release of a report
until another genotyping cycle has
happened
and actually a call was received whether
negative
or positive simultaneously
there's a different way to handle
variants
which might be failing in other in in
mutations which are not so important
that one maybe will not want to block a
report because their overall effect
on the detection rate is very very low
and with this i'm going to move you
into understanding what is
a the software of identify that can
accompany
the screening of preconception tests
expanded preconception tests because
naturally it might become very very
complex
to try to screen for 400 500 genes
or 1000 mutations simultaneously
in different populations so actually the
platform allows for four different
models the first of them is the access
which allows
it to actually give the
actually give the a way to
take medical history from a
a a given individual is being screened
and have all the data ready for the
later on calculations
of the ancestry and so on the next
module
is actually the model of analyze which
we know how to
integrate to row data
context and actually calculate
automatically
the carrier state and the residual risk
the next one will be
the insight model which will actually
allow us
to have all the data
reported in being ready for report and
then of course
to counsel and to release reports
to the patients
if any of you interested to have a full
demonstration of this software
we are very happy to show it elsewhere
but the overall value proposition is
naturally
to reduce the face-to-face interaction
with genetic cancers
to a to be able to screen many more
patients in the given
time frame and then we should conclude
by asking ourselves okay
what will what do we expect
we are going to do preconceptions
depending on the population
so as you can see there is
an example you can all look for it
that was published in the new york times
as an example so
testing of taizaks among ashkenazi jews
and you can see that it is concluding
that 30 years
later tizex is virtually gone
its incident slashed more than 95
percent
the disease is now so rare that most
doctors
have never seen a case so that's the
outcome of preconception screening of
successful preconception screening
and then you can also see that there are
declared missions
of ministries of health like this one
impact of a national genetic career
screening program for reproductive
purposes
and i've copied this last line here
finally expanding the existing test into
a uniform
why genetic panels seem to be the next
goal
so the vision
and the promise of expanded
preconception screening
is being fulfilled as we speak
and that is going to become yet another
critical pillar
for the preconception prenatal arsenal
of tests we can allow the productive
partners to use
like chromosomal micro analysis napt
and extended because i feel screening
with this
i would like to thank you all for
listening i would be more than happy to
receive questions now or again if you
want
to approach me later on then that will
be of course a pleasure to answer
the questions so thank you and
please have a question if you want to
thank you dr bear for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you would like to ask please just do so
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions
as we have time for other disease do you
foresee
discipline or becoming very rare thanks
to this expanded kind of screening
approach
so we i think that the the first
diseases that we would like to have
really good grasp of
are those that are of course making
most of the contribution to the sick
kids and that would be of course cystic
fibrosis in western populations
and then globally a duchenne muscular
dystrophy
thalassemia fragile x
so all the ones that are there and then
of course the ones we are going to see
disappearing are the ones that really
have an affiliation to a given community
so exactly as i said before the finnish
heritage disorders
disorders about amish about populations
that are
that we know that there is a an access
of genetic diseases in them
because of a strong founder effect so
that's what i would expect
and naturally a one should always
rethink about cystic fibrosis because
there are roughly 100 000 kids
suffering from physical brothers
worldwide and
basically with the current level of
preconception testing that we can offer
we can eliminate almost all cases so
that would be what i would envision that
will happen next
thank you another question is the
you mentioned the potential analysis of
hundreds of genes and thousands of lions
is there a way to restrict the list of
the violence if you want
yes absolutely that is actually a key
feature of the system
because different populations and
different regulatory agencies and
different
insurance companies might point
to a different number of mutations or
genes that they want to be screened for
so actually it is possible to
limit the number and actually to suggest
different offerings
to different patients from the same
clinic
specifically for these purposes so that
is a setup that of course should be done
first time and then can be repeatedly
modified if needed
but usually after a first good setup
then there is no need to do it again but
that the answer is
absolutely yes
another question and that's somehow
related to what you just said
it looks quite simple to implement this
solution but
are there challenges still to implement
the
exponential screening so
i think that of course the challenges of
introducing
any new method to the lab are they
you know pretty much the same people
need to be familiar
with the number of mutations that they
are going to be screened the number of
diseases which might be
a little bit overwhelming at the
beginning but this is exactly why
they are very strong both
laboratory validation processes and very
strong
software that is making life much easier
and we have very good experience with
laboratories adapting this
seeing that they are really becoming
mass production in laboratories of
justice so i would say that after
a period of uh adoption which will
usually be
you know a few weeks to a couple of
months this is becoming very very
routine
and they and that that should be of
course the case another thing that one
has to
one must realize that we saw it
a few times variants that were
considered to be pathogenic variants
once you start doing mess mesh screening
you see that they are simply appearing
too much in the population and then you
know that they can't be pathogenic so
this is a little bit of a of studying
during doing this but we have we have
not seen everyone failing in fulfilling
it
after a few weeks to a couple of months
so i would say that it's straightforward
solution now
thank you another question is
uh why asian people have a higher
prevalence of
cystic fibrosis oh they actually have
lower prevalence of cystic fibrosis
uh we don't know why it's always
remember when it is 1 in 24 in 125 in
caucasian
and 1 in 68 let's say in asian and that
means that asian actually have
less a carious date what are the reasons
for this
we do not know it might be local drift
effect
in most cases we we don't have a good
answer
in some diseases like sickle cell anemia
like thalassemia we do know that there
is a strong
benefit for the heterozygous
heterozygote carriers like from
being infected with malaria and this is
why there is excess of these
disorders in these populations but
it is it is true for many many
population genetics
let's say forces that are shaping the
genetic variation
in a given population are that it is
simply drift
and drift is a
thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question it's more technical question uh
what kind of input data format
is your software i'm using that would be
arrays
or ngs a and the
software can handle both platforms
and can also allow to integrate
a more uh more
results let's give a very trivial
example
usually both eraser and ngs are not
they are not a very successful with
doing
fragile x and then usually a third
method is needed
and the software we know also how to
absorb the results of this software into
a one coherent
report so i would say to make it brief
it would be array
ngs and then a
sum is needed for another for another
given variant
the software can do this as well
all right thank you very much dr gabriel
do you have any final comments for
our audience
alberta
i would be happy to only to receive more
questions so
if more examples are needed an actual
experience with the software that makes
it very easy
then please feel free do feel free to
contact
to contact me and i will make sure that
this
information and questions are being
answered other than this i want to thank
you all for
attending this presentation
thank you again dr bergen for your time
today and your important research
and as a sponsor of today's educational
webcast thumb official scientific would
like to
thank liverpool's for organizing the
webinar before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
the questions we didn't have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker
the other contact information you
provided at the time of
at this question this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab roots will
alert you via emails when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
bye bye